cap sur les antilles maintenant et sur
l'actualité sportive laurent bourgnon
pourrait arriver dimanche à pointe à
pitre le terme de la route du rhum il a
désormais une confortable avance sur le
second paul vatine dans l'ombre de ses
vedettes de la mer des complices qui
sont restés à terre pour étudier les
vents et pour choisir la meilleure route
françois brabant dans les histoires de
rome les lignes droites serra laurent
bourgnon et paul vatine ont tendance
depuis le départ à ne pas avancer très
droit à ne pas avancer côte-à-côte non
plus bourgnon jaune plus au sud
vatine rouge plus à l'ouest les deux
bateaux ont choisi de jouer avec les
vents de façon différente c'est le
routage pour paul vatine le routage x
fétiche à deux pas du pont de l'alma ils
font les zouaves avec leur ordinateur
la météo les images satellites les vents
l'âge du capitaine tout est décortiqué
par l'informatique pour proposer aux
skippers meilleure route possible
tel un jeu de piste sérieuse ok
confiance parce que pour qu'on puisse
avoir un dialogue entre personnes
confortablement installés puis le maroc
ou trempé qui complètement en train de
se battre avec les éléments il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient confiance parce
qu' il n'est pas question d'hésiter il
n'est pas question de dire temps mais
qu'est ce que tu me dis là qu'est ce que
ça veut dire non il faut vraiment que ce
soit clair simple et rapidement la pub
ici paul bhatti ne fait pas très bon au
nord rognon devront comme il en ce
moment mais se dirige rapidement vers
une zone de petites enceintes et killer
qui négocie et tous difficulté chris
paul dont on prévoir son action et nous
avons en ce moment faire on a le
stratégie est ce qu'on essaie de le
renvoyer d'abord en leur en est ce que
l'on va découvrir et se croit ces
quartiers que lui et c'est du béton par
contre elle dans l'ouest et c'est donc à
bata le sens des décisions à la fois
stratégique ou tactique par rapport au
dollar
on a un terrain de jeu qui prendra
section atlantique déjouer merveilleux
dégâts pour jouer avec un jeune parent
et paul vatine ne se gêne pas non plus
certains skippers gardent leurs
distances avec ce type de méthodes lui à
raison de trois liaisons radio par jour
les utilise à fond et ça pourrait lui
réussir haute-normandie fils aujourd'hui
à plus de 21 noeuds de moyenne deux fois
plus vite que laurent bourgnon et il
n'est plus qu'à 230 milles du leader de
la route du rhum